good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast and happy friday
friday gotta get down on friday
everybody's looking forward to the
weekend weekend friday
friday gotta get down on friday
oh my god feels so good it's such a
beautiful
stunning and smart friday especially
here in new york like the weather is
that gorgeous perfect fall weather and
it's a friday and
what more could you ask for no and i
just want everyone to acknowledge the
space that they're in congratulations to
you
you did this you raised the bar you made
it to friday no one else did it for you
absolutely not and we're just honored
really humbled and
humbled to be here and to be ushering in
you into this friday just call us usher
we're just so positive you know we are
radiating positivity even though like
i'm doing my absolute best not to give
in to my hangover like
i'm just a girl at work who happens to
have drink last night you know you can
do both plenty of people do it every day
millions of americans yeah like i'm just
gonna be giving my all to this show and
when i'm done with like with being the
ball of charisma uniqueness nerve and
talent that i am
i'm going to crumble okay but
i'm giving it everything i have that
sounds like a great plan did you have
fun last night tell us about the us open
it looks like it was covered you know
the us open is
such an event you know it's glamorous it
is an event that is true yes it's true
but you know every year i go i'm like oh
man this is so fun i should go more and
then i remember it like only happens
once a year for like two weeks yeah but
it was just really elegant and fun and
the celeb packed like me and brian were
eating dinner i mean they had such good
food in the emirates lounge me and brian
like could not stop going back up to the
buffet
and there were so many it was celeb
central wanda sikes
i saw
liza koshy
nice jesse palmer whom i literally
could not put my finger on who this
[ __ ] was like it was bothering
me so much because i was sitting next to
him and i was like can you see my seat
and then he was like can you save my
seat it's like we have this cute
interaction and i'm like you're a cheese
girl
literally
i was like you're either from a hallmark
movie or i could not he's actually from
a little bit of everything he's a former
nfl player he was the bachelor and now
he hosts daily mail tv so he does it all
no it was
and then i i literally like snuck a
picture of him and sent it to you guys
and i was like guys who the [ __ ] is this
jackie nailed it jesse [ __ ]
palmer and it's just like my night was
better after that once i figured it out
i once ran into jessie palmer on an
evening out and my night was made better
for it i'm not so charming like he was
so cute and i like said i'm a big fan
he's charming as hell
who's with a girl though i think that's
his leading lady she's
gorgeous same with the time that i was
out and i saw him he was with his
leading lady i love someone who just
like has a leading lady yeah
um so it was so fun and then like we
went down to the seats and like oh my
god i was living for the match because i
could see the sweat like brian sees were
amazing
and who was playing fernandez
i don't know who the other person was
because she lost but
she's this unranked 18 year old who's
just like made it the whole way and that
was the quarterfinals i think and she
won like it's an amazing story a true
historic moment cool and it was so fun
but like you know
it took like an hour and a half to get
there and then like
just by the time i got there like i was
really wasted like just because like we
were drinking in the car and then like
the car makes you drunk and it was just
like it all got like it all got away
from me so quickly and i was drinking
rose so it was like a i was like silly
you know did you have one of those u.s
open drinks oh my god okay so suddenly
everyone knows what the honeydew is or
whatever it's called like deuce
yes everywhere last night because i went
out afterwards people were like did you
have the honey juice i'm like why does
everyone know what that is brian got one
he's like you want one i'm like what is
it he said it's vodka i'm like no i'm
okay and everyone's like you went to the
us open and didn't have a honeydews
okay well now i'm annoyed that i asked
because i don't want to sound like like
everyone else it's a classic thing i
went to the kentucky derby not having a
mint julep you know
exactly i didn't know that that was a
thing okay next time everyone was
drinking these like pinkish purple
drinks and now i know what they are
hopefully you get invited again and
you'll write this wrong it was so fun
like really just a great way to spend a
summer evening
i'm so happy for you and it looks like
you found something to wear because you
were clothed
i did and it wasn't even that hard which
was just like a delight like put an
extra pep in my step amazing and brian
just got his new apartment in the city
so i went over to see it and like
honestly i wanted to kill myself we're
feeling inspired it's hard to see other
people living your dream he literally he
said it unprompted he was like think of
like you know the winter here like we'll
see the snow and i'm like what did you
just say maybe you should move in with
brian you guys could be roommates my
dream his tub was amazing
it's just gorgeous and now i'm like
obsessed with his building so like if i
it's like kind of stalkerish in me but
like what if i lived in the same
building as brian so fun so that would
be really fun that's the dream i've been
trying to get you to move into my
building i know but your building
doesn't have outdoor space actually this
one doesn't either i think i might have
to give up on that part of my dream yeah
you can't you don't get the whole dream
no i don't and honestly through this
process i'm learning i don't even get
like half the dream hmm
you get the degree minus two to three
can i ask you a question sure did you
watch addison ryan watch evans live no i
didn't because you know what i was
watching last night only murders in the
building did you like it i liked it so
much
there's four episodes did you watch oh
no one more came out
like i guess i'm like one ahead of you
you were right about everything selena
gomez is just like such a star she's not
distracted so convincing not distracting
but like every time i see her i'm like
what's she wearing what's she doing
right
and she really is giving me like a
little alex roos so i'm not going to lie
like attitude you know horse so it's
nice she's got that so it's so crazy
like we always say this but like no
matter how many how much people change
you know they metamorphosize like she's
still alex russo at the end of the day
totally so i really enjoyed that and
then i i didn't watch watch it up inside
because i completely forgot but i did
watch addison rey's
uh pizza review that's why i brought it
up because i wanted to talk about what i
watched this morning which was her pizza
review with dave portway and i have to
say like
i have never in my life
seen
someone as smitten with anyone as dave
portnoy was by addison ray and i don't
mean in like a romantic way i just think
he was like very taken aback by her
grace and her beauty and her maturity
because he was like smiling the whole
time he was like visibly smote yeah but
what's also so crazy is like he gets
such big stars on
pizza reviews he had machine gun kelly
and he's always like cool as a cucumber
and we were saying this about addison
but like she is like so a plus plus plus
list like she might be the biggest star
that he's had but he has so many big
stars you know no and i i could get the
vibe that like he was nervous like she
was just being effortlessly like cool
and it just made me and honestly like i
know i'm a hypocrite because like the
age difference but i shipped so [ __ ]
hard and like of course when it's like a
million scott we're like we cannot talk
about this this is illegal but now with
addison and dave porner like i think
that would be the cutest [ __ ]
couple of all time sorry like i said it
um i don't disagree you know she has a
boyfriend yeah and he's not it but she
seems really happy it's not fair she's
so giggly smiling she was just radiating
i don't even know like what the word is
she was like effervescent yeah on the
pizza review she didn't even like do
anything special she was just like being
star quality star quality and i really
like that that dave asked like how she's
been handling the fame because that was
like that was the lingering question
from the demilio show it's like what
happened to addison how's addison doing
and she shared that you know like it
definitely has been hard but it's gotten
better in recent months and i actually
like i there was i felt like there was
more to that story and i i you know we
said on the show that we felt like
addison was having an easier go of it
but perhaps she's not well i saw
yesterday that addison was on the not
skating but off that podcast you sent
that to me and i actually feel like
amanda who's obsessed with addison who
hosts that podcast will do like a really
good like i will be listening to that i
hope they recorded it i want to watch it
yeah because addison's just gorgeous
yeah
it looks like they were in the studio
that we were just in for media and they
do have cameras in there oh right yeah
so hopefully we get a video not to like
totally change
like the vibe of the show right now but
i've been thinking a lot
and like seeing so much content about
tomorrow being the 20th anniversary of 9
11. yes and i just like
i cannot i don't know why i'm like like
struggling with it like 20 years i'm
struggling with it too i'm glad that you
brought it up because obviously we don't
have a show tomorrow but that's right
something that we would have spoken
about
i'm i don't have the words for all of
the different feelings
that i'm feeling that i feel like
everyone's feeling there's been a lot of
like tributes yeah and um shows and
articles like you know on netflix
specials like specials and i i don't
know that i have the stomach i know to
watch 911 stuff makes me so emotional
like i'm literally gonna cry right now
i it's just a really heavy
day always the 20th anniversary and then
also just like
right now it's just heavy times and then
just like hearing people like we always
should like share like where we were i
think i was in the third grade and like
everyone was going home and we didn't
know what was up and the teacher i
remember my teacher was like there's
been an accident and i'm like okay
accident um
and just hearing other people's version
of like how
they
experienced it is really weird it's just
like
it's so it's so crazy and you're right
there have been like a lot of specials i
actually really want to watch robin
roberts interviewed like the kids of 9
11 like people who lost parents like
when they were like in middle school um
but there was also a special that was
like from the babies of 9 11 like
they were in utero and their dads passed
away oh my god so like they never met
their dads and now they're 20. oh my god
also
i did see another special it was like um
the uh i think maybe it was nine people
and maybe i'm getting confused because
last night they did like the first nine
women in the u.s open but like nine
female firefighters i saw that there so
like the women of the women of 911 yeah
i definitely want to watch that um it's
just heavy and i just feel like
i don't know i wanted to talk about it
yeah no i'm glad that you did because i
was gonna um
bring it up but there's never really a
good time to bring it a little bit
um
so
yeah
um but on a lighter note i'm drinking
out of my love island
water bottle and i think
i gotta
text i would feel like shaman when i do
that oh that's funny so you like the
water bottle
in the words of madison ray obsessed
addison
love her she's in the city like she did
not come on the toes i know but we
didn't even we don't even try like yeah
i know we were always like oh this
person didn't come on the chest right
did we reach out no totally i don't
think we could make it any indication
that that was something that we wanted
can i try something just between us and
the viewers yeah i like sometimes hate
having guests like
honestly not the interviewing part but
like the before
the social battery of it all like like
hi how are you like honestly like i'm
too like i'm like kind of like an
introvert i'm like not like other girls
you're the least introverted person i've
ever met no but when it comes to
the lead up anxiety for every interview
that we have even if it's on zoom like
it just like ruins my day it ruins like
my week until it happens and then it's
great yeah and that's always good but
like it definitely you've been loving
the term social battery because you know
what somebody
who i wanted somewhere i heard it
somewhere
and it's so accurate like i do not have
a lot of social battery
yeah i like the term
social battery pretty good yeah like
you're bad like my battery is like
constantly at a low yeah my battery's
really low these days i gotta head to my
recharging station ben's neck do you get
my reference i do oh so i started i told
you that the other book
that i thought was the sequel so it's
its own series i just found out and
people were telling me that that it's
amazing and like each series is better
than the next so i'm keeping with it
good because if i hadn't told you what
happens one summer is an amazing book
you would have read the beginning and
been like this is moronic
cheesy like
hallmark and that's how i'm feeling
about this book but the more i read
yesterday i was like oh my god like so
obsessed with travis and georgie like
need them to be together forever okay
good yeah i'm glad to hear we love some
positive reading news i'll let you know
when i've kind of
finished the series that'll be my next
update great that's a great journey for
you thank you what are you reading i'm
still reading the social graces uh the
social battery i'm like 65 of the way
through i really like it honestly it's
good i
but like then i don't know what i'm
going to read next i need just a series
or something or i need a new rabbit hole
i need her i need a new rap read
twilight [ __ ]
i don't know oh my god i sent jackie the
funniest tick tock yesterday about this
guy who lost his fantasy football league
and his punishment like from his friends
was he had to read twilight and then do
a book report like video testimonial and
he fell in love with twilight he
actually said he cried at the end of the
book and he gave the funniest book
report like for his like friends it was
the best thing i've ever seen and made
me wish i had a dad oh that's really sad
and sweet tick tock is always making me
do that like yeah wishing i had a job
well you just want to prank you send me
tick tocks like i asked you to do like
the funny ones the good ones and
you're just not sending me premium tick
tocks and then i think with tick-tock
you are such a [ __ ] pain in the eye i
think you would tic-tac that was funny
and you're like saw that so why don't
you send it to me because you know i
would have thought it was funny it was
about a silent disco okay honestly
because the effort that it takes to have
to send it in a text is so [ __ ] like
like with margo because we send them via
tick tock message you literally hold
down the screen press mario like it
couldn't be [ __ ] easier then i could
leave the uh apps copy link like torture
chad torture please because you're a
[ __ ] grandma who won't get with the
program no i'm i feel so every time you
send me a tick tock and it's not funny i
feel really good about my decision
because it feels as though your guys's
like bar for things that are funny is
getting lower and lower did you like my
um
[Music]
the twilight one though
i didn't watch it you are such a [ __ ]
you sent it at a bad time you sent it at
a bad time what time it was five o'clock
yeah that's the worst time of day for me
because that's when i'm taking my nap
so and then when i come out of my nap
i'm worse off and i need like an hour
honestly if i can be honest with you
these days it doesn't ever really seem
like a good time for you you're either
getting ready for your nap you're either
napping or you're just waking from up
from your nap like i know you have a
child but i'm still important too jackie
i give you an hour
and a half of my day work that doesn't
count unbridled and i call you
like 10 times a day and every time i
call you i say hello beautiful she does
what are you doing she does and i'm like
what do you want she's looking so
beautiful today she does i swear you
guys she's not lying she does do that
it's actually shocking she's like hello
beautiful you can be looking so gorgeous
or literally like a rat in your butt
and she's like oh my god you look
stunning
okay thanks jax you have such good taste
i'm ratting your butt shut up just let
it go no i wasn't trying to call you out
i was like that was funny no i was like
more so trying to say like you're
looking like a rat who like permanently
resides inside your own butthole like
that's i just didn't have time to come
up with like the good joke i was saying
that it's funny like you're just taking
everything that i'm saying is
adversarial and that's on you
by the way we agree like that is 100 on
me like i'm just i don't know like maybe
struggling with some self-esteem issues
that i'm like currently working through
or
or
less seriously it's just you know the
effects of alcohol
i know i say this all the time
but the effects of alcohol like i had so
much fun last night like i was just out
and about like living my best life
hobnobbing with celebs like you know
[ __ ] i lived for
and then and i would have traded i
wouldn't i mean i got into a fight at a
gay bar with margo oh i met snatcher
last night this she was looking gorgeous
she was looking gorgeous i hate to be
that person but like uh it was my dress
that she was borrowing be that person no
no but i feel like so i'm feel so good
about it because i gave her all of my
like little tiny dresses that i will
never [ __ ] wear again by the way you
know what you look like today who jesse
that's that's such a thing
i'm not doing the show anymore i quit
that's so mean i thought it's so i
thought you're gonna be like julia
roberts like
like
for those listening at the podcast
jackie's wearing like an over is that
zack shirt no it's from okay it's just
like a journey and i love brother i
think you look amazing i did not mean
that it is from
and you know that like they have these
big [ __ ] shoulders that are too big
for my shoulders
but here's the thing either
you need to leave or i'm leaving because
this this couch is too big for the both
of us the offense was too great i'm
sorry but by the way i feel like it was
so offensive to you because it's hella
accurate like you're just digging
digging digging sorry you don't want me
i don't think it takes away from the
fact that you look absolutely gorgeous
today and i really do love when you
walked in today didn't i say hello
fabulous i said you look fabulous
i really don't want this to take
anything away from your outfit
i just think you do look like jessie
say it again i dare you
say it again and you'll finally know how
it feels to do the show on your own
you look like chessy
no we have our first block off i feel
like we say that every time someone
walks off yeah no you know what i'm
a mature adult and i can
compartmentalize this offense
and i can forgive that's okay if you
want to tell me what i look like because
i know i look like a rat who permanently
resides inside my own butthole
i can forgive but i will not forget even
though you didn't even say sorry but
it's fine by the way
i don't really feel like okay i'm sorry
that the words hurt you i really am but
i just i think it's important to know
the intention behind them was so pure
okay does that help
i'm sorry
you know what yes and i'm going to
bookmark this incident because there's
times that i've said something to you
you take such events to it i'm like but
that's not how i meant it yeah and i'm
just going to say jesse
well okay i really dug myself into
jackie doesn't forget [ __ ] you guys like
i'm [ __ ] like i would never win an
argument like it's possible that i meant
like nothing nefarious so you just like
took it as a personal offense just like
the time you called me chassis you love
the word nefarious i do what does it
mean it just means
evil male intended yeah mel intended
okay yeah
cool well i feel like i'm ready to dive
in yeah i feel like we should dive in
that we were talking about something
before we got so sidetracked by chessy
oh we were talking about alcohol
oh yeah so like
today i'm like because honestly i was
reading like oh this is what i was gonna
say because and it's the only reason why
i brought it back up have you ever seen
an episode of watch it up inside with
john mayer where he talks about like why
he stopped drinking he's like the loan
shark it's just too high a price yeah
but also like i feel like john mayer has
like no real friends or family and like
that can be a lonely place waking up
hungover but like i wake up in my home
with my dog and my husband and i come to
work with my amazing gorgeous sister who
looks nothing like jessie and
and i never said she looked like jesse i
just said her outfit was heavily
inspired by her um i just feel like
yeah it's different
okay but what he was saying was like you
have like a few good hours on alcohol
and then you have you know 24 to 48
really bad ones and that's just like an
unfair price he doesn't want to pay it
anymore no when he said that but i love
that episode by the way i'm so glad you
brought that up [ __ ] with dan rather
than that solo
gorgeous um i loved that episode and the
logic is 100 right but i'm feeling right
now and that's why he said like he
switched to marijuana or whatever right
so even though i'm not feeling my best
right now like i wouldn't trade it i had
such a good time i was out about i left
my house at five o'clock and i got home
at 3am so it wasn't a few hours of fun
it was 10. okay so i stand by my
decision i really do
okay good
because it's the one you got i knew you
were gonna [ __ ] say that
okay without further ado
it is time for the fast five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
and today's up
episode today's episode is brought to
you by honey we all shop online and
we've all seen that promo code field
taunt us at checkout but thanks to honey
manually searching for coupon codes is a
thing of the past because honey is the
free browser extension that scours the
internet for promo codes and applies the
best one it finds to your cart they
support over 30 000 stores online and
they range from sites that sell tech
gaming products fashion food delivery
i've personally used it a ton on makeup
and clothes and it's really just like
it's a free money saver there's
literally no reason not to have it how
it works is that you're shopping online
when you get to the checkout the honey
button will drop down and all you have
to do is click apply coupons and if you
wait a few seconds they will search and
find a coupon codes for the site and you
will just watch the price that you have
to pay go down they found over 17
million members of honey
save save them two billion dollars in
savings so it's pretty legit i just
ordered a bunch of maternity clothes and
as i was checking out like honey popped
up and i was like yeah let's see what
honey can do for me and sometimes you
know i do doubt the powers of honey
but you regretted it didn't you i saved
i i i'm eating my words i saved a
hundred dollars i'm not surprised if you
don't already have honey you can be
straight up missing out on free savings
it's a completely free and it installs
in just a few seconds
you just have to go to joinhoney.com
toast that's
joinhoney.com
toast and you will get the browser
extension for free joinhoney.com toast
there's really no reason you don't have
honey already get with the program honey
first story you guys
ruthie close your ears
jonah hill confirms a new romance with
sarah brady in a must-see photo that's
disgusting it's
yeah before summer officially comes to
an end the actor decided to make summer
worse by sharing his romance with sarah
brady and making it instagram official
on thursday he took to social media and
shared a couple's photo from inside an
undisclosed restaurant he captioned the
picture saying grateful for you at sarah
brady not at ruthie
okay
so i feel like it's been a while since
we gave like a whole download on who
ruthie is and i don't even know if
rudy's a toaster and every time we talk
about he's definitely not she like she
doesn't [ __ ] with us at all i think she
entered whitney's protection
after witness witness protection i'm
like who's whitney
i just didn't know what it came out
sounding like
i think she ended witness protection
after everything that happened now we
will give the briefing on ruthie because
it's germaine to this story and every
time jonah hill has a new lady love we
must share you know the injustice that
happened to ruthie but i feel like we
did talk about it recently because he
was with gianna and they bought a house
right we were like should have been
roofie on that roof
ruffy
okay so here's the backstory so back in
the day we used to run this really hella
toxic facebook group and here's a
perfect example of why it was so [ __ ]
tough perfect example so this girl
ruthie was like
wrote in she's like oh man you guys i'm
freaking out like i am dming with jonah
hill like how do i be cool she was just
like asking for advice i guess like she
saw him on the street or something and
then like she dm'd him being like hi i
just saw you and like he remembered
because he was like oh he was very taken
by ruthie's beauty
how could he not be this is like like an
old wives tale now like because honestly
we never heard from ruthie again and i
feel like it was literally she was never
even here like
it's an urban legend lucy is living like
in australia with her twin sister and
alex mccord
so
she writes in the group she's like oh my
god can you girls help me like i want to
be cool and like i really want to go out
with him like
what should i say i'm talking to jonah
hill and like he was they were vibing
and it was all in real time and she was
really just came to the group like
looking for solace and and a lot of the
ladies in the group were like giving
good you know okay great advice like we
were all dming we all dna hill all dm
jonah hill and honestly like she came to
the group looking for
you know
sisterhood yeah and what she got she was
a knife in the back she no she got some
sisterhood
and a knife and then some
actual i don't even bridge troll thought
they saw the post this toaster
definitely not a toaster anymore saw the
the dms and all the whole thing
happening in the facebook group and she
took it upon herself to go message jonah
hill and be like this girl you're
talking to is blowing up your spot like
in a facebook group sending screenshots
from the facebook group
and honestly we should have known back
then that the facebook group was not
going in a good direction we should have
just saved ourselves all the heartache
and just closed it down then ruthie was
a cautionary tale but then obviously
jonah never spoke to ruthie again she
was so devastated and she really did not
she was doing nothing nefarious nothing
she was really she wasn't bragging she
was coming to the group for help
technically what the bridge troll said
was true like she was screenshotting
your dms and putting them in a facebook
group but in a non-nefarious way in like
ruthie non-nefarious way at all rosie
loved jonah for who he was no little and
all she wanted was it for it to work out
and she wanted her best possible shot
so i don't
know but the lesson here is i think it's
don't spend too much time in facebook
groups and that was like a a lesson we
needed to learn the hard way yeah
so he's moved on again ruthie lost her
shot
and now he's you know in relationship
after relationship trying to find that
connection that he had with ruthie and
that's why it's not working out because
gianna what's not ruthie sarah is not
ruthie but let's watch him try yeah
and i don't even
i love jonah hill by the way like i feel
like he's like one of my celebrity
crushes like not a physical way
well his i just love his work and like
his vibe yeah i agree he's a cutie yeah
like how he's like so like jokey but
also like
was it seriously in order to get
positive yeah yeah like i just feel like
he actually would be a great boyfriend
i'm sure and ruthie will never know what
that's like she'll never know and she'll
never be on the roofie
with ruthie
it's disgusting it's really it makes me
upset to even think about it it does so
anyways now whenever there's jonah hill
news like we're all just like okay
justice this is nice but justice for
ruthie and so if you go to the e-news
instagram so i was literally liking
every single comment all of the comments
on this picture where they talk about
this news or justice for ruthie and you
know i'm just gonna put out one i've
tried this before and we never heard
from ruthie but i just want to try one
more time like ruthie can i i want to
know what your life is like like i miss
you like
what like what do you do for a living
where do you live did you ever meet
jonah like i just want to follow up like
on this deer toaster it's like
i just want to know like are you still a
toaster if anybody knows the ruthie from
justice for ruthie by the way i love the
name ruthie like i'm obsessed um
please like reach out i just want to
know if she's doing well yeah and i just
want like a i just want to close this
chapter i do i feel like i haven't
really been able to move on in my life
since this story was just like ripped
out from underneath me that was the
worst day like it was atrocious it was
atrocious oh my god any and joanie just
keeps reminding us of it every time he
enters into a new relationship every
time he shows his face of course we wish
him the best
of course but we just know it's not
gonna work out because it's not ruthie
we're not psychic we just know
anyways we'll keep you posted on if
jonah and ruthie ever meet and we'll
keep you posted on if we ever hear from
ruthie again if somebody knows ruthie
then ruthie's not going to reach out
she's been burned once that's so true
rudy i will not tell anyone your secret
is safe with us secret safe with us
are you ready for our next story yeah
kim kardashian says her son saint broke
his arm in a few places oh my god and
she says he is not okay you know so
funny i was actually recently thinking
about how weird it was that like as kids
none of us ever broke a bone yeah it's
like very rare right kids do it all the
time all the time kids saint that's what
kids do
that's
what
kids do that's what kids they keep you
guessing the whole day through
play your emotions push all your buttons
that's what girls do
oh sorry i forgot we were doing a parody
honestly i'm feeling really stifled by
this triangle these days it's not doing
you want to graduate to a new english
it's not doing anything for me i'm
thinking like a tamarine okay or a set
of bongos okay i think you know we do
one level at a time yeah i'm just like
so definitely mastered the triangle and
maybe because like
we never
assembled it properly like the piece
that's supposed to you're supposed to
hold it at the top because we don't have
that i just feel like
this is moronic like no it's not it's
added so much value to our show what
other podcasts can say they have
triangles none and also it reminds me of
only murders in the building because he
has his harmonica
and that was like i mean the director
was way too hard on steve martin i agree
like he his voice is fine and the music
added a lot wait also
who's your favorite character in only
murders i think mine's martin short
mine's not martin short he's like a
little too chaotic and he's like
frazzled and like by the way are those
apartments gorgeous well not selena
gomez's but gorgeous yes truly and i
like the building i like the courtyard
me too um
my favorite character
it's probably celina right now wow got
to keep an eye out for selena
and you know what happens when you don't
murder's in the building only murder but
i gotta keep an eye out for celine
kim revealed that her little boy
suffered the unfortunate injury in a
slew of pose shared on her instagram
story on thursday
she first uploaded a picture of saint
sitting in a wheelchair while icing his
arm later the distressed mom shared a
photo of her son cradling his arm after
his cast had been set who do you think
cried more today my baby broke his arm
in a few places today i'm not okay
so sad so sad poor saint poor sainty
sainty her kids are really making a lot
of news these days did you see like
north went viral for like making fun of
her influencer voice no oh cause like
kim was recording like her videos and
you know when she like shoots products
yeah and so north was like why are you
talking like in the background and then
she's like you're talking like
north korea
and then i guess penelope was there too
and kim was like do i talk different and
they were like yeah oh my god calling
her out calling her out but i mean
everybody has their influencer voice
okay guys so
yeah i saw you did an ad yesterday you
were putting on major influencer voices
i feel like i was very true to myself so
authentic
i don't feel like there was an influence
or voice in the room okay i feel like my
influencer voices
no you're in your influencer voice i
know it it's like more high pitched yeah
like
and you sometimes throw a scream in
there what like
i've literally
never done that
ever i think that you have no
i don't even know like how to conjure up
that sound like
you know when influencers do that
they're like i can't believe i got this
oh you know they'd be like oh you guys
no i always say you guys but i think my
voice is like let me just hold on
hi guy no yes yeah yes hey guys welcome
back to my channel i'm so excited that
you're here i hope you all have an
amazing day and you're all fat and ugly
it just felt like being savage that is
it yeah hi guys
yeah yeah that's really funny honestly
like witnessing other people like put on
their influencer persona like in real
life is so cringy like yeah you could
die yeah i agree so that's how north
feels all the time i guess every single
day of her life that's really really
funny the life of north
are you ready for our next story only if
it's a story that's brought to you by
bruce oh it is the best electric
toothbrush on the market you guys we've
been telling you and you've been
listening but i feel like a lot of you
still don't have your bruce and you got
to get it because electric toothbrushes
can cost over 200 which is moronic but
they work really well bruce is literally
the best electric toothbrush on the
market and it's super affordable you
gotta go electric and you gotta go bruce
the bruce comes with six unique modes to
customize your brushing experience it
has a four week battery life a magnetic
charging stand and a compact travel case
they also offer a subscription program
so you never forget to change your brush
head again bruce will ship you a new
replacement head for your brush every
six months so you're never stuck using a
worn down brush head
brush's electric toothbrush has a modern
aesthetically pleasing design and it
comes in trend driven seasonal colors
and looks great on your bathroom counter
you know what i'm like really excited
about i know everyone's like excited you
know fashion week
spring summer whatever i cannot wait for
the fall drop from bruce i'm serious i
think i'm thinking we're gonna get like
auburn like maybe a
a chestnut i don't know like i'm just
saying
it's gonna be quite good no the trend
driven seasonal colors like they are
driving the trends and they're you know
they are they're trend driven
you get 15 off your bruce toothbrush kit
and the refill plan when you use the
promo code toast at bruce.com that's 15
off using promo code toast at brush.com
thank you for that claudia now i feel
great it's a pleasure i feel ready for
the next story good hold on just a
little burp oh some acid reflux getting
heartburn yet yeah i do get heartburn
especially at night like you know what i
really annoying i read that tums
actually give you more heartburn explain
they have like calcium or something in
them that contributes to heartburn but
it does also temporarily relieve and
it's honestly
a tum can
save your [ __ ] life like i
think tums are the most magical creation
i wanna you know
pray at the altar of toms like i think
they're amazing but when i learned that
it really devastated me damn i mean i
haven't taken times yet i believe that i
can take times but i also think that you
know heartburn gets worse later on in
the pregnancy so like i kind of
don't want to
spoil it yet yeah like by the way i've
heard from like millions of pregnant
women that like tums saves you
yeah i just like i just i'm always
waiting for things to get worse before
like i just that's really probably what
i miss most
in pregnancy is just like medication
right like something hurts let me take
something honestly feeling stressed
xanax i don't think i'll be able to do
that no it's it's probably like i miss
more than alcohol
just like a pill for every problem i
literally i don't think a day goes by
where i don't take advil or something
for like my head i mean obviously my
magical migraine pills just like
you
i just feel like you could take it like
i feel like you know if one of these
days i'm blessed with a child i'm just
really not gonna be able to like do all
these rules like i'm just gonna eat
whatever well everyone has to do what's
best for them so i wouldn't say you have
to do exactly what i'm doing but okay
what so i take advil and the baby's
headache goes away like you're welcome
baby
like what could be bad about advil i
just oh we using tylenol right
waste of time i know but at least it's
something no no it's nothing no if
you're in a dire situation like i have
had a tile and i'll save my life on
never maybe one occasion
you then you were fine to begin with
stop okay next story rebel wilson
reunites with her pitch perfect co-stars
for her 41st birthday she said bella's
be ballin
that's funny rebels have turned 40
rebels rebel may have turned 41 in march
but she still managed to celebrate the
occasion with a special group of friends
for her half birthday the actress
reunited with a number of her
perfect co-stars including anna kendrick
and britney snow on a tropical getaway
in tahiti in honor of her latest trip
around this time so [ __ ] fun it
really does she said bellasbee ballin
could not have loved these ladies more
ten years since we met and instantly
harmonized she wrote alongside a photo
of the group in the 80s themed swimwear
i love anna camp like i'm obsessed um
and i just don't know why her and skyler
aston didn't work out and i just read
the other day that like he broke up with
his
his other relationship just ended i feel
like it's him
it's definitely him you know
um this is really cute that they're all
friends still
yeah and you know they're like there
have been many things said about anna
kendrick like she's a nasty [ __ ] really
i don't know i feel like if you're nasty
[ __ ] like you don't become friends with
your co-stars especially less famous
ones like anna camp like
yeah anna kendrick is the one that i
just said yeah and anna camp now she's
there too oh yeah yeah so i'm saying
like you don't like rendezvous with your
co-stars from 10 years ago if you're
like a mean person well and like your
friend your co-stars sort of invite you
to rendezvous with them right in person
i don't recall hearing that about her oh
i have and it's all over jamaa she's
like known in the industry as like the
worst person ever what yeah
that's so the antithesis of like the
vibe that she puts out i just like which
makes it true right it's important lest
we not forget
she really got her career started um in
twilight
um and also that movie camp
is she in that movie i believe so
no i believe she is camp movie that
movie is so underrated it's about like a
theater cam yep anna karen drake all
these kids are dealing with their own
issues
oh who is she fritzy yeah yeah yeah
oh man that movie's so good and that's
singing at the end what's the song you
know what i'm talking about olivia
wouldn't know what i'm talking about
yeah i think i do know what you're
talking about is it um
what song did she sing at the end in
like that talent show where her jaw was
wired shut that was [ __ ] crazy that
was crazy you should just watch it and
give us a recap yeah that's a really
you know sometimes i've seen it in a
while so sometimes movies don't age like
when i recommend people movies that i
haven't seen in like 20 years no don't
recommend them to others like watch does
camp age well i don't probably not but
if you've seen it when you were young it
will still mean something to you when
you're older that's true you only watch
it for the first time like us with first
wives club it means nothing so true the
worst movie ever yeah but like or like
heartbreakers is one of those movies
where for me it's the best movie ever i
don't know jackie i'm telling you even
if you don't have a connection to it
heartbreakers is an unbelievable movie
really because when we recommend it for
toast movie of the week like
their views were mixed i can't just say
like how grateful i am to not be doing
toast movie of the week i was putting so
much of my we were doing toast movie of
the day literally like and i put so much
of my heart like into the selections and
and just for people to like hate movies
that i felt so connected to like was
really [ __ ] upsetting i'm sure that's
how people felt when we hated first
wives club like i think it was actually
a really toxic time and i don't want to
do it ever again i agree and we were
just trying to help
because we thought it was two weeks to
flatten the curves yeah we were gonna
watch a movie every day for two weeks
and it would be over but i did see some
i did see some movies i never would have
seen i was actually just thinking i
forget what it was of that scene in the
um was it the butler
when
i don't remember what i was thinking but
uh there were a couple movies i was glad
i saw but for the most part i really did
not enjoy people hating my movies
agreed and we have watched some great
movies shutter island oh my god that she
started it
um but no that
dark period of like the two weeks to
flatten the curve we supply on the curve
where we were just picking movies every
day like sleepover and like fun that was
like if we didn't do sleepover we never
would have gotten
truly corky
yeah but
the invention of lying i don't want to
trigger i don't want to go actually i'm
being heavily triggered i don't want to
hurt you
this is meant to be a safe space i just
want to say i stand by the choice for
the invention of lying like okay was it
a great film no have every time i've
seen it like i never actually finish it
yes i don't even know how it ends but
i stand by that like this utopic utopian
world
was like it was a good idea for a movie
like i stand by all of it i agree
i agree but then like people coming for
our from for our next just because of
that movie like
we didn't make the movie
we just made you watch it like it was
just toxic but also little
children please now you're you're
triggering me that movie is unbelievable
and i stand by that no patrick wilson
said it and he's hot you're hurting me
okay you're taking me to a place i don't
want to go to all right
next story the real housewives of salt
lake city's season two taglines are here
oh yes they came out a few days ago and
i keep meaning to make it a story and
i've forgotten until today oh i'm so
glad this is a good one okay
jen shaw first up the only thing i'm
guilty of is being shy amazing
and defrauding millions of americans
millions of vulnerable elderly
gullible americans
stop i cannot belie i'm sorry everyone
listening as a podcast like i've been
drinking this lacroix and i i cannot
stop burping into the microphone like if
you're if you think you're hearing
phantom burps you're not it's me and
i've been gaslighting you this whole
episode
um i can't believe she referenced like
her being a fraudulent
criminal queen guilty queen yes um and
like made a joke of it like i'm not
taking this gen shot case slightly
similar with erica jane like think of
the victims
jen shaw's what jen shaw is being
accused of is so horrendous
not only is she
defrauding people you know taking
convincing them to take car loans out
when they don't even have a car
but she's also then selling their
information to other fraudulent
fraudsters i know that they are like
susceptible marks yeah not dumb sorry i
take that back that was rude they're
trustworthy and
vulnerable and gullible i'm sorry i do
not mean dumb those actually really mean
i take it back
and i'm not letting her get away with
this
no me neither and neither is the fbi no
and neither is meredith marks
i'm obsessed with meredith marks so like
having her on the show i just want to
let you know when we were talking about
not liking having yes we were not
talking about meredith mark no we're not
talking about anyone in particular it's
just like you know the lead up to like
are we gonna do a good job it's just
like nervousness right yeah stage fright
next up mary cosby if you come for me i
will send jesus after you stunning i
guess they are coming for her this
season they're bringing up the cultivars
you know what there is a lot of
weirdness that goes on in mary's world
and i think it's time we address it i
mean it's only season two but it's time
we address it okay just like get some
clarity like there are rumors that
you're leading a cult do you it's a fair
question yeah meredith marks i may be
known for my ice but i always bring the
heat perfect really perfect because
she's icy like that's her thing but she
will bring the feet she's going to hold
jen's feet to the fire i guess i'm not
crazy i i feel like it's like because
it's salt lake city it's like i like
i think i like the the use of the
elements is meredith jewish
yes yeah such an interesting like group
of women they got like culturally yeah
it really is a great show i'm sorry i'm
not obsessed with meredith's i think
it's it's like on point you know it's
not like
the
the best most creative but it like sends
a strong message yes i like i like the
use of the elements in salt lake i
thought she was gonna be like
i may not be engaging
yeah yeah something like that
whitney rose in a town of beauties and
beasts there's only one wild rose
like i appreciate the beauty and the
beast reference but i don't see how it's
applicable
because her last name is rose yeah but
what does it have to do with the show
her she's the rose
like what does beauty and the beast have
to do with the show and who's she
calling a beast rose who are you calling
beast by the way did you see that
there's a new um
soap opera on peacock that eileen
davidson is in and lisa rinna got a role
and like they're two you know women
fighting in a cafe and they reenact the
beast scene like she like she slams the
glass she says who are you calling beast
it's actually so creative and funny it's
on danny pellegrino's instagram that's
why i saw it i didn't see it um
whitney rose i mean i understand where
she's going with it she seems random but
it's not my favorite yeah heather gay
i was raised a mormon but now i'm
raising a glass of champagne
okay like a transitional period in her
life it's okay it's not like slicing me
like it's not like oh it's like yeah
yeah and i mean raise and raise but
they're two different like tenses of
using right no i hate that no but i like
raisin raised
but i just
i was raised a mormon and now i'm
raising
it's not working for me
okay and you know what hers last year
wasn't good either like my pioneer
ancestors i'm blazing a trowel or
whatever like yeah but we didn't we
weren't expecting much from a season one
yeah but like she ended up being like a
queen of queens
and i just felt like she deserved a more
royal
tagline this one in particular is not
working for me yeah next we have a new
housewife jenny
there's a new housewife did anyone leave
no no i'm just curious like yeah no but
she in the trailer she seems great and
then her tagline is i have plenty of
everything including opinions
i mean those that statement in itself is
exactly what i'm looking for in a
housewife yeah i want someone who has a
lot of things and a lot of opinions
that's actually so true so i'm good with
that the sun is waiting on you right now
like gorgeous do you see chessy could
never jesse could never she's a cloud of
darkness
last one lisa barlow
i feel like lisa barlow might
might be our girl this season well let's
see because like she was so thirsty last
year at the end of the reunion to be
friends with jen shaw like her and jen
had buried a body somewhere and they
couldn't turn on each other it was so
weird because they hadn't ever even
spoken and now like i'm assuming she's
going to be taking a few steps back from
the friendship so we'll see she said you
don't have to like me i love myself
enough for the both of us
that's atrocious and that's good because
nobody likes lisa after the end of
winter heather storm weather bad weather
what was that i don't know but here's
what i'll say i didn't agree with
anything lisa barlow said or did last
season at all but i do respect that she
doubled down and made no apologies in
her longness who she was yes like didn't
just like i would have expected from her
to just be like thirsty and want to be a
fan favorite and just like try and like
back pedal on everything she did at the
reunion but i have to respect someone
who just like
stands up for what they did and said i
guess that's fair like
still don't like her but you're right
but that's just like you know
the silver lining what
lisa does that's a cheetah she keeps you
guessing the whole day through
this is a great episode i'm having so
much fun okay i'm about to ruin it
because our fifth and final story is
some losery tech news okay but hold on
oh yeah hold on what is it it's the
final story
you know that sounds like oh my god i
have ptsd
tell me what this sounds
like
the school bell yeah
you know the bell was the best like it
was freedom you know the bell or the
word it was prison or it was the end of
lunch it was either the key that
unlocked your cell
or locked your cell right up mm-hmm um
so it's the final story that's true but
what you failed to mention and you owe
everyone an apology is that it's the
fifth and final story brought to you by
noom
interesting i guess i will apologize for
that because i do not ever want to
take away from you guys the opportunity
to hear about new so let them know
claude are you sure are you ready i'm
ready if you are
noom has built their entire platform on
two things research and wanting to help
people lead healthier lives through
behavioral change so if you're looking
to make a change in your life for
whatever particular reason whether you
want to lose pounds you just want to
feel better you want to fit into certain
clothes you're
i don't know whatever your reasons are
you're entitled to them and you don't
need to explain and you don't have to
share them to me noom is something you
guys should definitely check out because
it's a psychology-based approach instead
of setting a strict set of rules newman
powers you with the knowledge to build
smarter more sustainable habits and
behaviors using a cognitive behavioral
approach you'll focus on the why instead
of the what to change your relationship
with eating
everyone's journey is different so noom
will customize the program for you based
on your personal goals
no food is considered off limits with
noob you can keep eating foods you love
while while learning to maintain a
healthier balance an off day is totally
okay and it won't set you off course
noon will gently help you back on track
noom only asks for 10 minutes of your
day to teach you about your eating
habits and check in on your progress
more than 80 percent of users can
complete the program and more than 60 of
users lose 5 percent of more or more of
body weight
if you want to sign up for your trial
and get psychology-based support and
motivation to reach your goals go to
noom.com toast that's n-o-o-m
dot com slash toast noom n-o-o-m dot com
slash toast i know jackie you've had a
lot of success with noom i have i love
nume it's just the best way to keep
track of everything that you're doing
and you know if you log enough
information you can see where you're
going wrong where you're going right
what you should increase what you should
work on decrease cut out um i think it's
the best way to hold yourself
accountable but also i just like
visually seeing you know what i'm doing
in a day what i'm doing in a week what i
did last month that i felt really good
last month maybe i should you know
sort of try and replicate it they have
so many great resources for people who
are starting out on their weight loss or
health or wellness journey that i
recommend it to everyone i know who's
like wanting to start you know a wedding
regime or regimen sorry or love a
wedding
or anything you know everyone has their
goals again you don't need to explain
yourself to us
but noon i would recommend.com
and i do recommend to have clearly
our fifth and final story losery tech
news i'm sorry to even bring this into
our fabulous show what is it
facebook and it's okay we can make it
great
we can make anything great funny we're
so funny facebook and ray ban have
paired up oh god a pair of smart glasses
starting on thursday the first pair of
smart glasses made by facebook and ray
ban are going on sale for 2.99 when are
we gonna learn like nobody wants
computer glasses like snapchat tried and
then google google tried and like they
were cool nobody [ __ ] cared the only
person who bought the snapchat goggles
was your husband yeah and you know we
did it we tried it and it was useless no
but he used to like come around to the
parties with his glasses on and like
film us like it was cool but it's like
even he didn't like it because where are
those glasses nobody knows literally
they're called ray-ban stories and
you'll be able to find them pretty much
anywhere ray-bans are sold including
lenscrafters and sunglass hut stores the
frames feature two front-facing cameras
for capturing videos and photos they
sync with a companion camera roll app
called facebook view where clips can be
edited and shared to other apps there's
a physical button on the glasses for
recording or you can say hey facebook
take a video to control them hands-free
and most importantly they do look like
regular ray-ban wayfarer sunglasses
heinous i'm sorry they look like the
free ones that you get at batman's fuzz
yeah and then they have like the colored
colored
handles you know yeah that was like katy
perry like hot and cold like i'm
personally so good i actually really
don't like that style of sunglasses me
too on my thoughts me too or everybody's
watch is different no i'm not into the
style like
at a glance some people are way fairer
people like it's very much a vibe not
for this big thotch
definitely not for this enormous punch
um
so
when will we learn when will we learn i
mean if i see anyone who i know around
me like
and you know i i give a pass to snapchat
lenses because like we thought that was
a good idea at the time like how fun and
everyone was excited about it everyone
was excited they were cute style like
rounded and people bought them i just
don't think they really integrated well
into people's lives like nobody had a
use for it so like i don't but i don't
blame like anyone including my husband
like i definitely don't like hold it
over his head that he like fell for that
um because it seemed it was a good idea
but now we are we know we're good and
also the tech on these cameras is
nothing near the smartphone like right
so if i see someone in my
life
coming at me recording out of control
i'm going to snatch those classes right
off their face do you ever think like i
wish i invented that
all the time what like i really wish i
had meant to the gopro like for a
million reasons one i think it's
literally the best piece of technology
like it does it all like literally the
the reality television industry is built
off the back of gopros like everyone
uses gopros now i think people capture
like such cool content like surfing and
[ __ ] and i just feel like it makes the
world a better place like i can't
explain it and i really and also the
guy's so rich that's really why i wish i
invented it yeah what about you
i mean
don't know i'll take anything really
that's like successful
um
you know what i mean
like gopro but the thing about gopro
it's like he didn't invent like a new i
think he didn't invent cameras and he
did right now we just did it really well
no and like he i think they
what do they sell for like eight billion
dollars or something like that should
have been me that's crazy i could have
made a mini camera yeah that's like
legacy box you know it's just like a
great idea that like you wish that you
had started i always think that i should
have invented legacy box because like we
and this is not an ad but like we used
to be those people like buying vhs
converters to try and watch our old home
cassettes yeah oh my god we're getting
so old like i was thinking about that
the other day
and how did that make you feel not great
i'm not gonna lie
but i'm also looking forward to putting
all this youth behind me i mean that
sounds like
really dark but
i'm just looking forward to like
relaxing you know yeah even though i
don't know do you like relax as you get
older i feel like life gets harder i
don't know well you definitely comes
with its fair share of challenges but i
do like i feel like you know
take out the pregnancy part like i feel
like i'm more relaxed than you yeah i
really want to be like in this place in
my life where like
you know i'm like i just turned like 45
like my kids are finally out of the
house and like i'm taking care of me
again like in a book or something you
know like i want to be that girl like so
i just do something crazy like i buy a
beach house like i don't know like yeah
i just like eat pray love travel but i
hope i i really hope i can afford a
beach house like yeah the only thing is
it's like if so if you were to be 40
your kids are going to leave the house
stop i know what you're going to say and
i should needed to have kids like five
years ago if i wanted that plan to work
shut the [ __ ] up okay you think i don't
know that you think i can't do math
i just i'll be fine tell me how you know
what i need to have this conversation
with myself how old will i be when my
kids leave okay here's the problem
45
when your kids leave and that's my
youngest kid your youngest kid you have
to have when you're 27 because then
they're 18. my youngest kid so you're
too late for that maybe you could be 50
and then your youngest kid you need to
have a 32.
yeah but like that would be nice to
start now it takes a long time you have
to wait a year to have a kid which by
the way is such [ __ ] like i should
just be able to order the child online
and like he should just show up or she
like it's [ __ ] yeah but i mean the
nine months i think we were talking
about this on the patreon like when
people are like how do you know that
you're ready to have a kid like i feel
like even if say you're not you're most
ready when you like find out that you're
pregnant like you have nine months to
get ready to get it together it's a
really long time of just sitting and
thinking about child right and you can't
like you know drink to to forget to
forget yeah no like you're doing it yeah
i guess you could eat to forget so you
could be 50 when
but you want to know something nice for
you 50. yes
i'll always be older than you that's
so true oh my god i feel better
that just make me feel good no i just
feel like for as long like you're 50 i'm
52. that's so true for as long as i can
remember like i've always been the
youngest person in the room and that's
because like i really do gravitate
towards older people like i'm always
hanging out with like you want to live
and your guys's friends and like i don't
know just everyone i'm friends with like
is always older than me and you also
started
your career very young yeah but now it's
just like oh you're just a girl with a
career you're not like crazy young for
your career like you're just a girl and
like the youngsters are coming up like
behind us and doing better like no and
they're like super young yeah super
young and super successful like
i just i've become so aware of my age
recently and i know like it sounds
moronic because yes i understand i'm 27
but like things are just changing like
life is
so [ __ ] short but it's also hella
long and like sometimes
it like things happen so quickly and
sometimes happen so slowly like i just
feel like i became 27 and like i didn't
really like do anything
you know like i just blinked and like i
was 27 and i was 24 like literally and i
loved being 24 like i love telling
everyone i'm 24. and when what were you
doing at 24 what year was that same [ __ ]
as i'm doing now just i was like uglier
and fatter right so look at that at
least something changed i don't have
that mole on my face anymore yeah and
like that's probably like
i saw a commercial yesterday for the new
york bariatric center like and it was
all these people being like
oh my only regret is that i didn't do it
sooner and like i was like yeah i feel
that that's how i literally feel about
my mole the fact that i got married with
my mole is actually one of my biggest
regrets i need to start a list because i
said my biggest regret was not getting
into the police car that's nothing and
then what was the other one that we were
referencing last night yeah yeah episode
like
whatever adding to the list
molly wedding
that's one of my biggest regrets i can't
even look at my time hop but like
doesn't that just show you how much ben
loved you
like no it's
now it's clear that i married someone
dumb and blind
because he married me with that mole on
my face and
i'll honestly nev honestly like
sometimes when he's sleeping and look
over and i'm like what kind of monster
are you
i'm not i'm being dead serious
dead [ __ ] serious can i just complain
really quickly about this water bottle
sure
like the straw is angled in a way so
like if i'm trying to drink the last
remnants you can't get remnants moronic
okay
i'll send a complaint to the
manufacturer and like it's a little
cheap like
this could come off at any minute i know
that's why it took so quickly to come i
guess i don't want to be complaining
because it's actually like one of the
best gifts i've ever gotten but you know
what if you like love it so much and use
it all the time maybe i'll take the time
to like go to like a
an etsy store
oh no i was going to say like to some
like to find you a bottle where it would
it's not a sticker no no like i love
this one like i don't want i'm just like
let's go get ready for my date
you do have to go get ready for your
date with you with ben and with ben the
monster
um so that is our show and i just feel
like it was amazing like i just feel so
good going into the weekend leaving you
guys with this i'm gonna like gonna
promote this one extra hard because i
just feel like have you been trying to
get your friend to become a toaster like
center this episode it was so good and
there's a lot of explanation justice for
right like i don't feel like we're
talking about stuff that you know only
we all know yeah even though those are
my favorite episodes too oh of course um
so i'm just like feeling really proud
and we did it joe we did it we did it we
did it jack we did it so that's our show
and i'm gonna wrap this up if you don't
have anything else to say no just um
have a great weekend you know take the
time to
commemorate the 20th anniversary
tomorrow
and just i don't know what what i don't
know what the right words are
i do
thank you so much for listening to the
morning chose the monday morning show
where we deliver the festive stories
that you need to know every monday
through friday on youtube so if you're
watching this on youtube please feel
free to subscribe and give this video a
thumbs up we're also available as a
podcast and we're podcasting we found
some spotify itunes stitcher public
video i have already cast box all the
places listening podcast five nights
morning chelsea five star viewers
beautiful
and tomorrow we are
if you made it to the end of the episode
congratulations you are now part of the
society season two and to let us know
that you have made it here please go
drop an emoji on our most recent
instagram account perhaps the emoji for
monster
okay how you interpret that monster i
think there's like a big red one have a
great day everyone great weekend
actually and we'll see you on monday bye
you